待って絶対ないもんだって
財布なくしました。
ガチです今日は。なんか今なくして
新幹線…JRさんに連絡して
新幹線の席まで見てもらったんですけど無いって言われて
このパターン初じゃない？ちょっとまって急ごう本当に
いや待っていつものパターンじゃないよこれ。いつもだったら絶対新幹線で見つかるから
財布をなくしたと思われる３つのパターンが考えられます
以上の３つが考えられます
とりあえずはじめしゃちょーは静岡駅に向かいました。そこで駅員さんに聞いて
中に入ることが可能か聞いてみました
絶対馬鹿だと思われてますね
しかしゴミ箱を探すことの許可をゲットしました
改札をくぐるときの入場券を買います
動揺しています。財布もカードもないのにクレジットゾーンで買おうとしていました
ホントに焦ってる今
あｗホントですかｗ
千円札が取れなくなっちゃいました…
やべえｗ不幸が重なり続けてるｗ
あぁ！ああ！びっくりしたｗ
返ってこなくなっちゃったわ
千円どういうこと？取られたの？？
あとであとから考えよう
あとで考えよう
あとはゴミ…
捨てられたか捨てられてないかで
僕の人生が決まります
ゴミ…漁っていいって言われたもんね？
待って、俺の捨てたコンポタージュが残ってる。ほら
どうしようゴミが無い、まず
いよいよヤバいよこれは
じゃあ落し物行こう、次は
ここにいなかったらいよいよおしまいだぜ
財布の落し物とかってあります…？？
えっと…１３時３４分の品川発のこだまに乗って静岡に来たんで…
駅員さん「こだま降りるときはあったんですか？」
いやーその瞬間からもちょっと…車両も調べてもらったんですけど
無かったんで多分
駅かなと
駅員さん「こちらの方にご連絡致しますので…」
こうして、
ゴミ袋にも辿り着けず、
落し物にも無く、
はじめしゃちょーの財布は、なくなったと思われた
その３日後…
お久しぶりです。はじめしゃちょーです
財布をなくして、３日が経ちました
昨日…
見つかりましたぁ…
今回本当に、もうだって
東京から帰って新幹線も探した、静岡駅も探した
かばんも全部探しました
品川駅にも電話しました。全部電話したんですけど結局見つからなくて
で、やべぇもう本当に今回は無いって思ったんですけども！
なんとこちら…東京駅にて見つかりました
よかった( ノД`)…
見つかってよかったよぉ(;´Д⊂)
とりあえずもう、もらいに行きましょ
駅員さん「じゃあこちら、ちょっとお名前を先ちょっといれてください」
はい、はい
駅員さん「財布は…
えっと二つ折りの…小汚い…茶色…
マジで焦った今回は
祭りに行ってなくしたとかさ、新幹線そのまま行っちゃったとかあったんですけど
なかったから
あ…！あ…！あ…！あ…！！
駅員さん「まずじゃあ、こちらですね」
駅員さん「中ちょっと確認させて…ATMはね別にして２万２千６９９円」
２万２千６９９円
駅員さん「よろしいですか？」
はいっ
駅員さん「ではこれでOKですよ～」
はい、すみませんありがとうございましたm(_ _)m
駅員さん「はいっ、お疲れ様～」
ああ～～
よかったぁマジでよかった～
はいというわけで、無事財布見つかりました
もうほんと忘れたくないんすよ
僕もそんな忘れようと思って忘れてるわけじゃないし
まぁけどこうやって無事帰ってきてよかったです
とりあえず金パクられなくて
よかった♡
ED